TIM ANDERSON: Hi, and welcome
to Tech Tips from Teachers.
On this episode, we'll be
looking at creation tool apps.
Our guest today is
Elizabeth Calhoon
from San Jose, California.
Elizabeth currently
serves as the manager
of educational technology
for a large Bay Area
office of education,
and previously
was a high school
teacher, and also
served as vice principal
for a middle school
and a high school.
She also holds a Master's
in Educational Leadership.
So Elizabeth, why is technology
so important in the classroom?
ELIZABETH CALHOON:
Technology opens the doors
for kids around the world.
It opens the doors
to information.
to other teachers,
as well as to other
students, so that they can
learn from and with the world.
TIM ANDERSON: And then with
the creation piece of things,
how does technology
help to enable that?
ELIZABETH CALHOON: Well, the
best part about technology
now is that it's not
just about consumption.
It's that you can, in fact,
create, and anyone can create.
And so students now can
feel empowered by the fact
that they can learn
all of this information
from around the world,
take it in, and then create
so that they can contribute
to the world's information
as well.
TIM ANDERSON: We've
heard from teachers
that there a few key components
that make creation tool
apps especially applicable
to the classroom.
It's important that
they're versatile,
that they make sharing
easy, and that they
have simple, easy to
use user interfaces.
Why is it so important
that apps are
versatile for classroom use?
ELIZABETH CALHOON: Because
classroom environments
are versatile.
And a teacher's
environment, depending on
whether they're working
with a first grader
or they're working with a
third grader or a sixth grader,
is going to change on a
regular, perhaps daily, basis.
And so they need
to be able to have
an app that they're presenting
to their students that
has longevity and
that they as a teacher
can use across grade
levels, in addition
to developmental levels.
Finally, I think the
reason versatility
is really important is
because a lot of teachers
are making lots of
movement towards being
collaborative with
their colleagues
across content areas.
So I may be an English
teacher, but I really
want to do some work
with the science teacher.
I want an app that's going to
be able to bridge those two
content areas and we
can work with together.
TIM ANDERSON: Gotcha.
That makes sense.
And then with that
sharing piece,
why is that something
that's so critical?
ELIZABETH CALHOON:
For teachers to be
able to have an app where a
student creates something in
and then they're able to share
it among any of those programs
is hugely important.
The teacher
shouldn't be spending
time trying to figure
out the mechanics
of how do I export this, and
how do I make this meaningful?
How do I share it with parents?
How do I share
with the community?
Those are the really
rich experiences,
being able to share it
with a larger community.
But if the teacher
can't even get it out
of the device in
the first place,
or put it into a program they
already have in their district,
they're not going to use it.
TIM ANDERSON: And
then that last point
about having a really
simple, easy to use UI.
Why is that something that
you would urge developers
to put at the forefront?
ELIZABETH CALHOON: Everything
we give to our students
is vetted through us first.
We look at movies
before we show them.
We try to play with an app
before we give it to a student.
And one of the pieces that I see
teachers do time and time again
is that if somebody
hasn't walked them
through a complicated
application, sometimes
they're not willing to
give it to their student,
because they need to feel
comfortable with it first.
TIM ANDERSON: Elizabeth, tell
us about Explain Everything.
Why is it so great?
ELIZABETH CARLTON: It
is so fantastic mostly
because it is so versatile.
One of the great use
cases that I've seen
is with elementary students.
The teacher will create
a sample and then
show that to the students for
them to then recreate or create
their own version of.
It encourages group work.
It encourages them
to work together
to pull in from a variety
of different sources.
It also allows for
this cross pollination
between content areas.
So if I'm an English
teacher, again,
I want to work with
a science teacher,
Explain Everything
is going to cross
those boundaries no problem.
TIM ANDERSON: What
about Book Creator.
In this sea of creation tools,
what makes that app stand out?
ELIZABETH CALHOON: So
Book Creator's really fun
because you're creating a book.
It has this wonderful
sharing capability
that provides for teachers to
be able to share with students,
students to share with
other students, and then
ultimately, for
students to share
their books with the parents
or the community at large.
And their knowledge
and their learning
then becomes very
transparent and public.
TIM ANDERSON: And then
what about Comic Strip It!?
What makes that such a
nice fit for the classroom?
ELIZABETH CALHOON:
One of the things
that's great about it is that
you have to actually synthesize
a bunch of information in
order to create a comic strip.
And that can be a
difficult mental process
to go through to synthesize
information and make
it very concise.
And so the cleaner
the user interface
is when you're creating
something as complicated
as that process can be,
the better the result is
going to be.
So with Comic Strip It!, you're
able to take the information,
put it in a nice,
neat little box.
And you have fun doing it.
TIM ANDERSON: Elizabeth, thanks
so much for joining us today.
It was great having you.
ELIZABETH CALHOON:
Sure, thank you.
Thanks for having me.
TIM ANDERSON: And to
recap, with creation tools
in the classroom, a couple of
key things to keep in mind.
It's important that
these apps are versatile,
that they make sharing easy,
and that they have simple user
interfaces.
For more episodes of
Tech Tips from Teachers,
check out the Google
Developers YouTube channel.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]